hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today um i wanted to
watch
the new trailer for the medium this is
from gamespot official 14 minutes of
xbox series x4 play
4k gameplay trailer um this is a game
i'm super interested in it's from blue
batem who i really really like
and i think they are doing a similar
sort of world switching thing
as ratchet and clank which is something
that in terms of
next-gen tech is really interesting to
me so
i thought that we would watch this
trailer i love a spooky game but i also
again technically
very interested in this one so let's
watch it shall we
um i know the game did get delayed
sort of recently but yeah for anyone who
doesn't know bluebird team made
layers of fear they made the recent
um witch game my goddamn hats get out of
here
this immediately looks like control
um so yeah i expect it to be a similar
kind of spooky
also i'm covering it but just so
everyone knows it does say game footage
not final on the screen right now
a shoe i hate those
it's very dramatic
very dramatic but i will say an object
doing stuff like that is pretty similar
to leia sophia
the neva massacre i need to find this
thomas guy and get the hell out of here
okay yeah okay you find thomas
hello i wonder what this building is
anyone
thomas you there
hotel niwa hmm
definitely getting control meets until
dawn vibes right now
a flickering light
my lost enemy
hello
thomas
spooky or magic
easy to confuse the two is it spooky or
is it magic
old-fashioned haunted hotel calm your
ass down
and answer the bell
i would love if this is like silent hill
but we'll see i guess
hell no dude this is going to scare the
[ __ ] out of me i'm
terrified okay it's fine it's fine
ah it's me
you startled me i did didn't i
you look real scared
i'm sadness mary anne
sadness is she aware she's in a
different
plane i mean you seem pretty cheerful to
me
well it's what i remember
my friends used to call me by a
different name
but i don't remember what it was
your friends oh yeah i used to have
a lot of friends here
hmm did
something happen to them
uh i don't really want to talk about it
that's okay
i feel like i'd be more weirded out by
this [ __ ] showing up when she showed up
all by yourself
you wouldn't believe how boring it gets
sometimes
i can imagine this
place must have been oh yes
so busy people
coming and going
all
oh my god our own c3 you should get that
looked at
so
tell me what happened
uh i remember
people stopped coming only a few of them
stayed but
they became very sad so i think the top
is
showing us that they might hurt you
she is still in that physical space
that i can take care of myself she's
just seeing
the bottle i was wondering have you seen
mary anne
yes oh the stairs watched you play with
me
no god no
it's been so long absolutely not okay
but i need your help we disagree marion
get the [ __ ] out of that
yes yes
anything
do you know him uh
let me think uh
i've heard that is that like a whole
body missing take your time
oh yeah the second floor
we can look there come on hurry wait
i can't go that way
why not oh because you know it's broken
in the real world
that's interesting so you can't walk up
things that
i wonder oh it does play in both
hmm
interesting
i forgot what i was saying i was saying
something
hey an elevator
huh might as well see if it works
[Music]
they are technically running
two games at once sadness release two
levels at once i wish
i knew her real name i'm gonna have to
ask mike bethel about this
[ __ ] no okay marianne
just take a deep breath and
[Music]
need some energy to spark it up so then
you can leave your body to solve
problems in the other world that you
would then jump back in your body
when they're done i'm into it i'm into
it
an out-of-body experience it's like
a team games in the past um while i
think this term is overly reductive
and sell some short have been walking
simulators really occasional puzzles but
really all you do is walk around
um and it's not like this is not
still technically a lot of walking and
mindly interacting with puzzles but i
feel like this is a massive gameplay
extension
of what they've done previously in a way
that um is really neat
what's happening to you are you fading
away what is happening to your body
okay marianne where your legs go now get
your ghostly ass back and power up that
elevator
oh she can tell what back that makes
sense
[Music]
i'm into it
oh no there's an ad i'm gonna have to
cut oh no
i watched the ad so you wouldn't have to
it's done
i oh [ __ ]
the cat it stayed on the other side
i'm stuck here that was a cat did i miss
something
when the [ __ ] was there a cat
what's happening no is that the cat
is that what the cat sounds like plot
twist
oh god what happened to you
wait i know you you were that boy
bernard was it
he was trapped there just like i was
i knew his name but somehow that wasn't
enough to send him away
it was like a part of him was missing
that was cool
all these people they weren't just
killed
their spirits i'm a huge fan of lighting
broken beyond repair
maybe i can find the one bernard's
missing
i need to look around yeah the lighting
on that blood also all that sound is
awful
[ __ ] i've never heard bugs sound like
that in real life though not one time
i could use some of that energy
that's cool
this was yours wasn't it bernard
it's about time you got it back
like blue team have this like really
unique way of doing storytelling
that's uh you can see through here i
think
i'm sorry you had getting resident evil
vibes from this too it's time for you to
find
peace bernard
thank you
all right it kind of looks like the one
i used to get through the mirror
feels like it too
oh jesus chase sequences bro
yes yes
did not like that you made it marianne
oh my gosh no there are chase sequences
in layers here too
oh god oh god oh god yeah so watching
this is not that bad but if i have to
play this i'm gonna
[ __ ] myself which i will because i will
definitely
how he not gonna realize that her light
is flashing dude that is what's flashing
right
oh will he opens the door this another
ad come on game spot come on
all right we did it
wait what just happened was that a
transition
the ad really screwed the timing up
did we walk outside the lighting is
really nice
big invisible boy
the lighting mechanic reminds me of um
phasmaphobia where it's like
is it flickering because you're being
stalked really closely does it get
faster as he gets closer
or something maybe he's hot in your
trail
i think it might well like destroying
where are you out
oh that seemed risky it seemed like you
could take a big risk there oh my gosh
distraction i have no choice but to
respect
there that's my way out
not with that thing in my way
there you go january 28th 2021
um i was gonna play this game regardless
i'll probably play everything the blue
team make if i'm completely honest
uh combat combat's not the right word
gameplay definitely looks a lot more
involved than i expected it to so
um props for that what is it coming out
on
you know it's xbox
it's also epic and steam so xbox console
exclusive but
yeah it looks good it looks good it's um
it's cool to see them grow in this way
so i i thought the voice acting was
really nice too
and uh huge fan of the lighting look
spooky as hell i would have been
terrified playing that so
sign me up all right see everyone bye